[Applause]
a desperate and futile scramble to save
their homes within a few hours nothing
but debris people try to salvage what
little is left to the authorities these
makeshift houses were built illegally
but for the people here this was home
and many don't know where to go these
men are asking why did they do this
where will they sleep what kind of
country is this where those with
air-conditioned homes are destroying
poor people's homes but for some it's
also their livelihoods we were able to
evacuate those few chickens but many
died they surprised us and started to
demolish they broke everything up this
was once part of a labyrinth of homes
that house tens of thousands it's
situated on the outskirts of Abidjan
International Airport
that's where earlier this month teenager
Laurent Bethell Amin hid in the landing
gear on an Air France flight his
lifeless body was found by flight
officials in Paris believing but the
element hidden in the shantytown before
jumping the fence onto the runway the
government ordered the adjuvant a burr
hood evacuated to clear a 200-meter
safety zone Communications Minister city
twain said these occupations post air
safety and security problems a while
most of the people living here were
given 45 days to leave many was shocked
when the first diggers rolled in this
week I was born here I've been here
nearly 40 years even the mosque was
destroyed we said at least leave the
mosque but they destroyed everything we
got what we could from our homes
residents say the government is not
dealing with the crux of the issue the
high cost of living in a country where
almost half of the population lives in
poverty and it's poverty they say
that led to the teenage boys escape and
them having no choice but to live near
the airport now many have nowhere to go
Laura Burton Manley aljazeera